Tasha: 3级
Tasha: Level 3
Tasha: 要3级然后走连败
Tasha: We need to reach level 3 and then lose continuously.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Lucia: 你在找什么
Lucia: What are you looking for?
Jake: 没有在晃悠
Jake: Nothing, just wandering around.
Jake: 开工吧
Jake: Let's get to work.
Jake: 上班了上班了
Jake: Time to work, time to work.
Jake: 拆快递 2楼可能得收拾收拾
Jake: Unpack the packages. Maybe the second floor needs tidying up.
Jake: 你们今天做狗吗
Jake: Are you guys working with dogs today?
Jake: 今天看狗吗
Jake: Watching dogs today?
Lucia: 平时可以做
Lucia: We can do it usually.
Lucia: 到底是做狗还是看狗啊
Lucia: Are we working with dogs or watching them?
Jake: 都可以做
Jake: We can do both.
Jake: 可以看看狗
Jake: We can watch dogs.
Jake: 要不我们建立一些逻辑吧
Jake: How about we establish some logic?
Jake: 作为一个
Jake: As a...
Jake: 这个也是什么f人还是什么人
Jake: This is like being an f-person or something.
Jake: 建立一些联系
Jake: Establish some connections.
Jake: 我们先看狗
Jake: Let's start by watching dogs.
Jake: 然后按照狗去做狗
Jake: Then follow the dogs to work with dogs.
Lucia: 建立逻辑是替人
Lucia: Establishing logic for people.
Jake: 替人好
Jake: Good for people.
Katrina:  那就是先小红书看一点狗的款式
Katrina: So, we start by checking out some dog styles on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina:  然后开始选择
Katrina: Then we start picking.
Katrina:  然后再做 建立一种逻辑
Katrina: Then we proceed and establish a kind of logic.
Lucia: 我需要一支笔
Lucia: I need a pen.
Lucia:  就是只要只要能只要能画个大概就行
Lucia: As long as I can draw roughly, it will be fine.
Lucia: 头暂时还不需要过多考虑
Lucia: We don't need to think too much about the head for now.
Lucia: 哦   点
Lucia: Oh, just a dot.
Tasha: 三阶段就能卡着利息升8级我靠
Tasha: By stage three, we can hold interest and reach level 8. Damn.
Nicous: 告密者
Nicous: Informer.
Lucia: 在我的眼镜突然被转歪的时候
Lucia: When my glasses suddenly shift...
Lucia: AI会不会以为地震了
Lucia: Will the AI think it's an earthquake?
Jake: 那可能地震频率过高
Jake: Maybe because the earthquake frequency is too high.
Lucia: 是不是个好问题
Lucia: Isn't that a good question?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 也没有很经常吧
Lucia: It doesn't happen that often, right?
Jake: 好好
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 我只是刚才突然转到线了而已
Lucia: I just suddenly turned to the line just now.
Jake: 那没电了
Jake: Then it's out of battery.
Jake: 确实和地震
Jake: Indeed, like an earthquake.
Lucia: 我需要一根笔老板
Lucia: I need a pen, boss.
Jake: 什么笔
Jake: What kind of pen?
Lucia: 随便什么笔
Lucia: Any pen will do.
Lucia: 能在纸箱上面画出来线就行
Lucia: As long as it can draw lines on the cardboard.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 还有我们之前买的彩笔是还没到吗
Jake: And the colored pens we ordered earlier, have they arrived yet?
Lucia: 好我们已经实现无纸化工作了
Lucia: Well, we've gone paperless already.
Katrina: 刚到刚到
Katrina: Just arrived, just arrived.
Lucia: 现在没有笔是吧
Lucia: So, no pens now, right?
Jake:是的
Jake: That's right.
Jake: 是没到是吧
Jake: So they haven't arrived yet?
Shure: 我们要不要臆想出来一只纸狗
Shure: Should we imagine a paper dog?
Lucia: 因为我害怕一直用这白板笔
Lucia: Because I'm afraid of using this whiteboard marker all the time.
Lucia: 给他用没墨了
Lucia: It might run out of ink.
Jake: 嗯买买买
Jake: Hmm, buy, buy, buy.
Jake: 所以没到还是还是怎么回事
Jake: So they haven't arrived yet or what's going on?
Jake: 之前买的这个笔吗
Jake: The pens we ordered earlier?
Katrina:  刚到刚到
Katrina: Just arrived, just arrived.
Katrina: 刚到刚到菜鸟驿站
Katrina: Just arrived at the Cainiao Station.
Jake: 哦那就还能领是吧
Jake: Oh, so we can still pick them up?
Jake: 今天还能
Jake: Today?
Jake: 今天就能拿到了
Jake: We can get them today.
Jake: 催他们一下
Jake: Follow up with them.
Tasha: 墨菲流丝带来娜拉可西
Tasha: Murphy brought Narcos.
Lucia: 雨轩有那种普通的写字的笔
Lucia: Yuxuan has those regular writing pens.
Lucia: 但是我感觉往完了纸上可能有点
Lucia: But I feel like on finished paper, it might be a bit...
Lucia: 有点细好做标记的话所以
Lucia: It might be too fine for making marks, so...
Jake: 那就去取快递
Jake: Then go pick up the package.
Tasha: 他虽然能上7个人
Tasha: It can hold seven people.
Tasha: 但是的卡牌里面的那个概率还是那个
Tasha: But the probability in the card deck is still that...
Tasha: 那个等级概率啊
Tasha: That level probability.
Jake: 走把二楼给收拾收拾给你们跳舞
Jake: Come on, let's clean up the second floor, and I'll dance for you.
Shure:  二楼有什么
Shure: What's on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼有饺子
Jake: Dumplings on the second floor.
Tasha: 哎呀你这连胜没吃到呀
Tasha: Oh, you missed out on the winning streak.
Lucia: 我决定也来压压花吧
Lucia: I've decided to press flowers too.
Lucia: 这个怎么做呀
Lucia: How do you do it?
Katrina:  特别简单
Katrina: It's super simple.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: You just...
Lucia: 稍等
Lucia: Hold on.
Lucia: 这个是不是暂时还用不到
Lucia: Do we need this right now?
Lucia: 我先放起来
Lucia: I'll put it away for now.
Lucia: 我们需要用到的是哪些呀
Lucia: What do we actually need to use?
Katrina:  就这一套
Katrina: Just this set.
Katrina:  嗯下面是海绵
Katrina: Yeah, the bottom is a sponge.
Katrina:  然后垫一层这个然后垫一层纸
Katrina: Then put a layer of this, then a layer of paper.
Katrina: 中间在放一层 然就汉堡包一样
Katrina: Put a layer in the middle, like a burger.
Katrina:  垫一层这个垫一层这个
Katrina: Layer this, layer that.
Katrina:  这是干燥板
Katrina: This is the drying board.
Katrina:  然后把它包起来就好了
Katrina: Then just wrap it up.
Katrina:  然后各种花你可以上网看一下
Katrina: You can look up various flowers online.
Katrina:  有的人建议是弄花瓣
Katrina: Some people suggest using petals.
Katrina:  像这种小花就可以直接压
Katrina: Small flowers like this can be pressed directly.
Katrina:  大花的话像我那天压出来效果不好
Katrina: For big flowers, like the ones I pressed the other day, the result wasn't good.
Katrina:  我这次打算把它这样侧着压
Katrina: This time, I'm planning to press it sideways.
Katrina:  看看会不会好一点
Katrina: Let's see if it turns out better.
Katrina:  我上次这样压你知道吗
Katrina: Last time I pressed it like this, you know?
Katrina:  这样压确实这样散了
Katrina: Pressing it like this really spread it out.
Lucia: 哦中间这个就比他们高很多
Lucia: Oh, this middle part is much taller than the others.
Katrina:  芍药的话我是扒了外面的
Katrina: For peonies, I peeled off the outer layers.
Katrina:  因为他这太立体了
Katrina: Because it's too three-dimensional.
Katrina:  这样压不了
Katrina: Can't press it like that.
Katrina:  就扒了外面的粉色大片
Katrina: So I peeled off the big pink outer layers.
Lucia: 或者能不能把这里给他修剪
Lucia: Or can we trim this part?
Katrina:  可以他们说也可以
Katrina: Yeah, they said you can.
Katrina:  也可以把压这一块
Katrina: You can also press this part.
Katrina:  这个可以放网上教程
Katrina: This can go in the online tutorial.
Katrina:  我感觉我也不太熟悉
Katrina: I feel like I'm not very familiar with it.
Lucia:这个是怎么放的看看你的
Lucia: How do you place this? Let me see yours.
Katrina:  最下面一层海绵这样子
Katrina: The bottom layer is a sponge like this.
Lucia: 先这个对吧
Lucia: This first, right?
Lucia: 然后放一层海绵
Lucia: Then a layer of sponge.
Katrina:  干燥板放一层干燥板然后放一层纸
Katrina: Drying board, then a layer of drying board, then a layer of paper.
Lucia: 这个白的的东西这里面好像没有
Lucia: This white thing doesn't seem to be in here.
Lucia: 这里面好像没有哎
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be in here.
Katrina: 干燥板
Katrina: Drying board.
Lucia:噢那个在那
Lucia: Oh, it's over there.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then...
Katrina: 就放纸
Katrina: Just put the paper
Katrina: 纸上就放纸花
Katrina: Put paper flowers on the paper
Lucia: 然后就可以放花了啊
Lucia: Then you can put the flowers on
Lucia: 所以就是这里面可以垫好几层海绵
Lucia: So you can layer several pieces of sponge here
Lucia: 放好几层花
Lucia: And put several layers of flowers
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah
Lucia: 这张有点有点折的
Lucia: This one is a bit folded
Lucia: 都有点折
Lucia: They're all a bit folded
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Just leave it like this
Lucia: sorry 我成功把它成熟一个非常短的视频
Lucia: Sorry, I successfully made it into a very short video
Jake: 好好
Jake: Alright, alright
Lucia:我现在再来一个再来一个
Lucia: I'll do another one, another one
Jake: 有快递拆吗
Jake: Any packages to open?
Jake: 没有那下午干什么
Jake: If not, what do we do this afternoon?
Jake: 什么都可以
Jake: Anything is fine
Jake: 有快递拆吗
Jake: Any packages to open?
Jake: 那下午干什么
Jake: Then what to do this afternoon?
Jake: 打金铲铲
Jake: Play some games
Katrina: 唉
Katrina: Oh
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 我要
Katrina: I want to
Jake: 你应该有很多花要压
Jake: You should have a lot of flowers to press
Jake: 然后还需要有人帮你压花
Jake: And you'll need someone to help you press flowers
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Lucia:我正在试图压花
Lucia: I'm trying to press flowers
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 二楼要不有空收拾收拾
Jake: Maybe we can tidy up the second floor
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go
Alice:小狗在哪
Alice: Where's the puppy?
Jake:狗在
Jake: The dog is here
Jake: 你是活狗还是死狗
Jake: Are you a live dog or a dead dog?
Tasha: 哈哈我天哪
Tasha: Haha, oh my god
Jake: 活活哈哈哈活狗
Jake: Alive, alive, hahaha, live dog
Lucia:死狗还没做出来
Lucia: We haven't made a dead dog yet
Katrina:  咖啡店那个吗
Katrina: The one from the coffee shop?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes
Katrina: 走哇 可以拿过来
Katrina: Let's go, we can bring it over
Alice:咖啡店在哪
Alice: Where is the coffee shop?
Jake: 活狗可以看一看
Jake: You can check out the live dogs.
Jake: 咖啡店我我没去过
Jake: I've never been to the coffee shop.
Jake: 据说200米很近
Jake: They say it's only 200 meters away.
Lucia: 我们可以先用自己的理念构思
Lucia: We can start with our own ideas.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Hmm, right.
Jake: 然后看画的狗和真正的狗长不长
Jake: Then we'll see if the drawn dogs look like the real ones.
Lucia: 马非马
Lucia: A horse that isn't a horse.
Jake: 走我们把二楼收拾收拾
Jake: Let's go clean up the second floor.
Jake: 没事的兄弟姐妹们
Jake: It's okay, everyone.
Tasha: 啊可以
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Katrina: 啊 又忘记给他买那个
Katrina: Ah, I forgot to buy that for him again.
Lucia: 啊啊啊这这朵枯萎了
Lucia: Ah, this flower has withered.
Lucia: 好消息是我的芍药开始想开了
Lucia: The good news is my peonies are starting to bloom.
Lucia: 逐渐想开
Lucia: Slowly starting to bloom.
Lucia: 应该看外面
Lucia: Should look outside.
Lucia: 我又把我手机放哪了
Lucia: Where did I put my phone again?
Katrina:  所以那个衣服怎么说来着
Katrina: So, what about those clothes?
Katrina:  衣服
Katrina: Clothes.
Tasha: 说是租吧
Tasha: I think we should rent them.
Katrina:  先下桌
Katrina: Let's do it offline first.
Tasha: 线下也可以
Tasha: Offline works too.
Katrina:  那线上要下单不现在
Katrina: Should we order them online now?
Tasha: 可以我看了一家了
Tasha: Sure, I found a shop.
Katrina:  请你发群里吧
Katrina: Please share it in the group.
Katrina:  能让大家报一下尺码
Katrina: So everyone can report their sizes.
Lucia: 这花是它
Lucia: This flower, is it...
Lucia: 准备谢了还是它没没开
Lucia: Is it about to wilt or hasn't bloomed yet?
Katrina:  应该快要谢了
Katrina: It should be wilting soon.
Katrina:  不然它边边上都那个
Katrina: Otherwise, its edges wouldn't be like this.
Lucia: 但它里面就是里面的花瓣有好硬
Lucia: But the petals inside are quite hard.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 要不这个吧
Lucia: How about this one?
Lucia: 这个花形
Lucia: This flower shape.
Lucia: 哈哈哈圆一点
Lucia: Hahaha, it's rounder.
Nicous: 这你都能输啊
Nicous: You lost even this?
Tasha: 我打的是连败啊
Tasha: I'm on a losing streak.
Tasha: 你看我五级星3尊者
Tasha: Look, I'm a level 5 star 3 master.
Tasha: 一回合可以吃10个金币
Tasha: I can earn 10 gold coins per round.
Nicous:  五级星被你搞基了
Nicous: Your level 5 star got messed up by you.
Tasha:靠我也五级星
Tasha: Damn, I'm also level 5 star.
Tasha: 你看你强度怎么上这么高
Tasha: Look at how high your intensity is.
Nicous:  我搞个够吧
Nicous: I'm just going all out.
Nicous:  我就五级星
Nicous: I'm only at five-star level.
Tasha: 哎你猜一个一一一
Tasha: Hey, guess what, one one one.
Tasha: 才从一开始
Tasha: Starting from scratch.
Tasha: 有什么好伤心的
Tasha: Why are you so upset?
Tasha: 就相当于是一个装备拆卸器
Tasha: It's like an equipment disassembler.
Tasha: 你把它放到备战席上
Tasha: You put it on the bench.
Tasha: 他装备就掉下来了
Tasha: The equipment will fall off.
Tasha: 没有啊你97滴血
Tasha: No, you still have 97 health.
Tasha: 你转啥都行啊
Tasha: You can switch to anything.
Tasha: 你可以先先用五极星玩个三连
Tasha: You can use the five-star level for a triple combo.
Tasha: 玩到你看你这不是还要几个回合
Tasha: Play until you see, you still have a few rounds left.
Tasha: 还要五个回合才能收菜嘛
Tasha: You have five more rounds to harvest.
Tasha: 你收了一波菜之后你再转嘛
Tasha: After you harvest, you can switch.
Tasha: 转啥都行
Tasha: Switch to anything.
Tasha: 不就是我吗
Tasha: Isn't that me?
Tasha: 还有第二
Tasha: And the second one.
Tasha: 赛娜
Tasha: Senna.
Tasha: 你多少级了
Tasha: What level are you?
Tasha: 玩赛娜
Tasha: Playing Senna.
Nicous: 6级
Nicous: Level 6.
Tasha: 好吧 6级可以玩
Tasha: Okay, level 6 is fine.
Tasha: 哎呦这人傻逼吧
Tasha: Oh, this person is stupid.
Tasha: 为什么他打不过我呀
Tasha: Why can't he beat me?
Jake: 听说你把心如干蒙了
Jake: I heard you stunned Xinru.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 你你现在是第几
Jake: What rank are you now?
Tasha: 我现在是这个名字
Tasha: I have this name now.
Tasha: 但是其实我只是一直在打连败的
Tasha: But actually, I've been losing streaks.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 心如现在还是短暂的第一名是吧
Jake: Xinru is still temporarily first place, right?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 但是你还是把他打蒙了
Jake: But you still stunned him.
Jake: 他也想连败的
Jake: He also wants to lose streaks.
Tasha: 他也想连败的
Tasha: He also wants to lose streaks.
Lucia: 他浅浅的破防了
Lucia: He got slightly frustrated.
Tasha: 他想要连败
Tasha: He wants to lose streaks.
Tasha: 我也想要连败
Tasha: I also want to lose streaks.
Tasha: 但他连败不过我
Tasha: But he can't beat me even consecutively.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 笑死我了
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter.
Jake: 笑笑死我了
Jake: Laughing, I'm dying of laughter.
Jake: 这个很难解释
Jake: This is hard to explain.
Jake: 不知道怎么怎么解释
Jake: I don't even know how to explain it.
Lucia: 好难啊
Lucia: It's so hard.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 看下小红书教程吧
Katrina: Check out the tutorials on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina:  我也是瞎做
Katrina: I just wing it too.
Lucia: 看了但是感觉就这种厚的花
Lucia: I looked, but it seems like thick flowers like this
Lucia: 就是很容易会缩
Lucia: tend to shrink easily.
Lucia: 我在想你有什么办法让它不缩
Lucia: I'm wondering if you have any way to keep it from shrinking.
Katrina:  那你就可以压这种小花这样一放
Katrina: Then you can press small flowers like this and put them there.
Lucia: 对对那种小花好压一下
Lucia: Yes, those small flowers are easy to press.
Lucia: 但我这个小的感觉它现在开的很旺盛
Lucia: But this small one is blooming so vigorously now.
Lucia: 我有点舍不得把它剪下来
Lucia: I feel a bit reluctant to cut it off.
Katrina: 残忍的咔咔
Katrina: Just cut it ruthlessly.
Jake:剪一半
Jake: Cut it in half.
Lucia: 还可以这样
Lucia: You can do that?
Lucia: 那剩下可以是可以啊
Lucia: But the remaining half will be so lonely.
Lucia: 但那剩下的一半就会很孤单
Lucia: But that remaining half will be so lonely.
Katrina:  但我这卖不出去啊
Katrina: But I can't sell it like this.
Lucia: 没事我们又不用真货币
Lucia: It's okay, we're not using real money.
Lucia: 而且
Lucia: And
Lucia: 你接下来这个肯定会做的非常成功的
Lucia: you'll definitely do a great job on this one next.
Lucia: 第一次那个只是试验品
Lucia: The first one was just a trial.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Alright.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 哎对齐一下不
Jake: Hey, should we align this?
Katrina:  你买那个钟
Katrina: Did you buy that clock?
Lucia: 是干嘛的
Lucia: What's it for?
Jake: 那个钟就是每一层放一个
Jake: That clock, you place one on each level.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 就是每一帧都知道时间对不对
Jake: So you know the time for each frame, right?
Jake: 就是可以测试用
Jake: It's for testing.
Jake: 其实每一帧都是有时间
Jake: Actually, every frame has a timestamp.
Jake: 就是对一下
Jake: Just to align them.
Lucia: 理论上说拍电影是应该这样的
Lucia: Theoretically, for filming movies, it should be like that.
Lucia: 不过我鉴于我们这个不是电影所以
Lucia: But considering this isn't a movie, so...
Jake: 哎你看过的对吧
Jake: Hey, you've seen it, right?
Tasha: 看过了嗯
Tasha: Yeah, I've seen it.
Lucia: 我觉得就他吧
Lucia: I think it's him.
Lucia: 撕下来
Lucia: Tear it off.
Tasha: 我打不过你
Tasha: I can't beat you.
Nicous: 你别又打不过我
Nicous: Don't tell me you can't beat me again.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Nicous: 你刚刚才赢的
Nicous: You just won.
Tasha: 你赢不是好吗
Tasha: Isn't it good if you win?
Tasha: 你看我打不过你
Tasha: See, I can't beat you.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How about that?
Jake: 你们两个人只能交锋一次是吗
Jake: You two can only face off once, right?
Nicous: 哎哟 我草 我破防了
Nicous: Oh man, I'm breaking down.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake: 骂游戏了
Jake: Cursing the game.
Jake: 是吧你看
Jake: Right, see?
Lucia: 我说他浅浅的破防哈哈哈
Lucia: I said he was slightly breaking down, haha.
Nicous: 她跟我说撸把撸把 撸把
Nicous: She told me to keep playing, keep playing.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha
Nicous: 没关系可以玩
Nicous: It's okay, we can play.
Nicous: 就玩成这样子了
Nicous: We ended up playing like this.
Tasha: 可以玩
Tasha: We can play.
Tasha: 哈哈你看你还在第一名呢
Tasha: Haha, look, you're still first place.
Tasha: 这不是一个好兆头吗
Tasha: Isn't that a good sign?
Nicous:  我草你刚拆我的背景当狗擦
Nicous: Damn, you just tore my background like a dog.
Tasha: 哎我刚刚也被人破防了一次
Tasha: I was also broken down once earlier.
Tasha: 好吧我到现在才六几名
Tasha: Well, I'm still in the sixties.
Nicous: 还好是哪个人我给他
Nicous: Alright, who was it? I'll get them.
Tasha: 叫蛰伏他已经走了
Tasha: His name is Dormant, he's already gone.
Nicous: 我靠
Nicous: Damn.
Lucia: 浅浅的观摩一下
Lucia: Just a shallow observation.
Katrina:  我这一层是厚的
Katrina: This layer is thick.
Katrina:  之前压的花瓣
Katrina: The previous one was pressed petals.
Katrina:  这一层试验品
Katrina: This layer is experimental.
Tasha: 你几级啊你
Tasha: What level are you?
Tasha: 6级你知道我要上10级了吗
Tasha: Level 6? You know I'm about to reach level 10?
Tasha: 马上哈哈
Tasha: Soon, haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake: 上面桌子搬完了吗
Jake: Is the table upstairs moved?
Shure:  擦完了
Shure: It's cleaned.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay
Alice:可以跟狗玩吗
Alice: Can we play with the dog?
Katrina:  狗你得
Katrina: The dog, you need to...
俢硕：狗在咖啡店
Shure: The dog is at the café.
Alice:狗在哪呢
Alice: Where's the dog?
Katrina:  对它还没进行社会化训练
Katrina: It hasn't had socialization training yet.
Shure:  对它会咬你
Shure: Yeah, it might bite you.
Katrina:  对啊但它没长啥牙
Katrina: Yeah, but it doesn't have many teeth yet.
Katrina:  没事两三个月
Katrina: It's fine, just a couple of months.
Katrina:  小边牧浴哥是咖啡色啊
Katrina: The little Border Collie puppy is brown.
Lucia: 好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute!
Katrina:  是很可爱超可爱
Katrina: Yes, super cute.
Alice:能找狗玩吗
Alice: Can we find the dog?
Katrina:  你去啊但是我忘了是左拐还是右拐
Katrina: You go, but I forgot if it's left or right.
Katrina:  哦不对
Katrina: Oh, wait.
Katrina:  好像是我们这
Katrina: I think it's this way.
Katrina:  出来以后
Katrina: After you come out...
Katrina:  往哪拐
Katrina: Which way to turn...
Katrina: 反正走
Katrina: Just keep walking.
Katrina:  完全不需要
Katrina: No need at all.
Katrina:  那店主很佛系
Katrina: The owner is super chill.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 有股营养液味
Lucia: Smells like nutrient solution.
Tasha: 别说是我了
Tasha: Don't say it's me.
Tasha: 不是吧OK
Tasha: Really? Okay.
Tasha: 啊sir
Tasha: Oh sir.
Tasha: 用点力啊
Tasha: Use some force.
Tasha: 哦靠居然赢了
Tasha: Oh wow, I actually won.
Katrina:  嗯这花怎么会有黏黏的东西
Katrina: Hmm, why is this flower sticky?
Katrina:  这是它的什么蜂蜜
Katrina: Is this its honey?
Katrina:  你可以先学
Katrina: You can learn first.
Shure:  不行我不能投入大
Shure: No, I can't invest too much.
Shure:  大家卷我绝对不是这样的人
Shure: I'm not the kind of person who goes all in.
Katrina:  天呢后天生的
Katrina: Oh my, born with it.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What happened?
Tasha: 狠狠把他暴打了
Tasha: Beat him up hard.
Tasha: 现在开始
Tasha: Starting now.
Katrina: 他下来了呵
Katrina: He's coming down, haha.
Katrina:  他来了
Katrina: Here he comes.
俢硕：人家不爆杀你嘛
Shure: They didn't blow you up
Shure:  随便杀他装备都没上呢
Shure: They killed him casually without any equipment
Shure:  略施小计就把你玩的团团转谢彬竹
Shure: Just a small trick and you're totally played by Xie Binzhu
Shure:  你就是这样被女人玩弄的
Shure: This is how you get played by women
Shure:  是不是
Shure: Isn't it
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What
Lucia: 哎就唱给你吧
Lucia: Hey, let me sing for you
Katrina:  你最后一天啥活动来着
Katrina: What’s your last day activity again?
Katrina:  你怎么不用干活呢
Katrina: Why aren’t you working?
Lucia: 哎搞点
Lucia: Hey, doing something
Shure:  我最后一天什么活动
Shure: What’s my last day activity?
Shure:  我是一个
Shure: I am a
Katrina:  是每个人都要有个ID啊
Katrina: Everyone needs an ID, right?
Lucia: 我想看看这个
Lucia: I want to see this
俢硕: all nice
Shure: all nice
Lucia: 这个这
Lucia: This, this
Lucia: 比如说这层放完剩下再放一层纸是吗
Lucia: For example, after placing this layer, do we put another layer of paper?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes
Katrina: 再放一层干燥板
Katrina: Then another drying board
Katrina:  再放一层纸
Katrina: Then another layer of paper
俢硕: 我我是建立这个经济体系的人嘛
Shure: I am the one who established this economic system
Katrina: 再放一层干燥板再放一层纸
Katrina: Another drying board, then another layer of paper
Shure:  你忘记了吗
Shure: Did you forget?
Katrina:  哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh
Katrina:  明白了
Katrina: Got it
Shure:  我的唯一任务就是把货币做出来
Shure: My only task is to create the currency
Katrina:  货币已经买了
Katrina: The currency is already bought
Shure:  OK解决
Shure: OK, problem solved
Shure:  伟大无需多言
Shure: Greatness needs no words
Jake: 落地了是吧
Jake: It landed, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes
Jake:伟大的构想
Jake: Great idea
Shure:  是的
Shure: Indeed
Shure:  你知道我国第一个货币叫做什么吗
Shure: Do you know what the first currency of our country was called?
Shure:  让我
Shure: Let me
Alice: 修币
Alice: Shure Coin
Shure:  那出出现在哪个哪个朝代
Shure: Which dynasty did it appear in?
Katrina: 在拿一盒
Katrina: Get another box
Jake: 包比比
Jake: Bag Bibby
Shure:  宋代的骄子
Shure: The pride of the Song Dynasty
Jake: 哪真的呀这是
Jake: Is this for real?
Alice:没见过姣子见过饺子
Alice: Haven't seen a Jiazi, but I've seen dumplings.
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure:  需要帮忙吗
Shure: Need any help?
Katrina:  还有一个板你想做也可以做
Katrina: There's another board. If you want, you can make it.
Lucia: 在这边吗
Lucia: Is it over here?
Katrina:  什么你要板吗
Katrina: What? Do you need a board?
Lucia: 对刚才
Lucia: Yeah, just now.
Katrina: 来吧用掉吧
Katrina: Here, go ahead and use it.
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Lucia: 明明记得刚才在这边有
Lucia: I clearly remember there was one here just now.
Lucia: 但是这样吧找不到了
Lucia: But it seems like it's gone now.
Katrina:  夹汉堡包
Katrina: Grabbing a burger.
Tasha: 我觉得利桑卓在这个版本最厉害
Tasha: I think Lissandra is the strongest in this version.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Tasha: 5费卡里面
Tasha: Among the 5-cost cards.
Tasha: 那刀妹和猴子的话就猴子厉害点吧
Tasha: Between Irelia and Wukong, Wukong is stronger.
Katrina:  唉哟我直接用新的吧
Katrina: Oh well, I'll just use the new one.
Tasha: 拿个什么呢
Tasha: What should I take?
Tasha: 哒哒哒
Tasha: Da da da.
Lucia: 太厚了的话我改变一下策略
Lucia: If it's too thick, I'll change my strategy.
Tasha: 就抢个无敌2把
Tasha: Just grab an invincible one.
Tasha: 这把我追
Tasha: This time I'll chase.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Tasha: 我靠你到底要什么你说嘛
Tasha: Come on, just tell me what you want.
Tasha: 你可以拿第二的
Tasha: You can take the second one.
Tasha: 我可以把第二的位置让给你牌给你
Tasha: I can give you the second position, give you the cards.
Shure:  你等他快三星5费的时候你就点了
Shure: Wait until he gets close to 3-star 5-cost, then click.
Nicous: 肯定点
Nicous: Definitely click.
Jake: 谢彬竹还能拿个第二啊
Jake: Can Xie Binzhu still get second place?
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: So impressive.
Shure:  说实话
Shure: Honestly.
Shure:  其实其他6个应该都是人机
Shure: Actually, the other 6 should all be bots.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 所以输不过他们
Tasha: So you can't lose to them.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Jake: 哦人机很牛逼
Jake: Oh, bots are impressive.
Shure:  不是所以他一个人类都没有几百
Shure: No, so he's the bottom among the humans.
Shure:  他就是人类中的倒数第一
Shure: He's literally the last human.
Shure:  我们这左侧的这个RGB是干嘛的
Shure: What's this RGB on the left side for?
Jake: 它就是光
Jake: It's just light.
Tasha: 就打我
Tasha: Just hit me.
Jake: 它就是白光
Jake: It's just white light.
Jake: 然后它往这边它就它就分了
Jake: Then it comes this way and splits.
Nicous: 你能不能打过别人
Nicous: Can you beat others?
Tasha: 我谁都打得过
Tasha: I can beat anyone.
Tasha: 不你为什么不玩第二名
Tasha: Why don't you play second place?
Nicous: 没有区别
Nicous: No difference.
Nicous: 第一第二和第三有什么区别
Nicous: What's the difference between first, second, and third?
Tasha:哈哈干嘛呀
Tasha: Haha, what are you doing?
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 1只两只3只5只
Tasha: One, two, three, five.
Tasha: 这个还差4只
Tasha: There are still four missing.
Shure:  这个什么都想追
Shure: You want to chase everything.
Shure: 你好贪啊
Shure: You're so greedy.
Tasha: 这个不追了
Tasha: I won't chase this one.
Tasha: 就追你们几吧
Tasha: I'll just chase you guys.
Tasha: 这个不追了
Tasha: I won't chase this one.
Tasha: 会有几个了
Tasha: How many are there now?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 还差两个会
Tasha: Still two more to go.
Tasha: 还差几个
Tasha: How many are left?
Shure: 哦你要会是吧
Shure: Oh, you need two more, right?
Tasha: 会还差两个
Tasha: Still two more.
Shure: 哦我这边还刷到1个现在两个
Shure: Oh, I just got one here, so now two more.
Tasha: 无敌2 无敌2
Tasha: Invincible 2, Invincible 2.
Tasha: 还差3个会
Tasha: Still need three more.
Tasha: 哎三星乌迪尔了
Tasha: Oh, three-star Udyr now.
Nicous: 谁啊
Nicous: Who?
Tasha: 就这样我等等呀
Tasha: Just like that, I'll wait.
Shure:  没有那个是镜像过来的
Shure: No, that's just a mirror image.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  你不给他装这个了吗
Shure: Aren't you going to equip him?
Tasha: 哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 不是我装的
Tasha: It's not me who equipped it.
Tasha: 这是神器变的
Tasha: It transformed from the artifact.
Shure:  what's this
Shure: What's this?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  bomb has been planted是吧
Shure: Bomb has been planted, right?
Shure:  炸弹已经安放
Shure: The bomb has been planted.
Tasha: 唉好难追啊
Tasha: Ugh, so hard to catch up.
Jake: 我靠这东西还能搞闹钟
Jake: Whoa, this thing can even work as an alarm clock?
Katrina:  你做那小狗呗
Katrina: You should make that puppy.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 你帮他做那个小狗
Katrina: You help him make that puppy.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  今儿小红书搜搜然后做
Katrina: Search on Xiaohongshu today and then do it.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Shure:  今天中午说你做那个小狗呗
Shure: You said at noon today to make that puppy.
Tasha: 我刚不是差两张吗
Tasha: Didn't I just need two more cards?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我把一只两星的卖了
Tasha: I sold a two-star one.
Tasha: 在干嘛哈哈哈
Tasha: What are you doing? Hahaha.
Shure:  教教我这个怎么做
Shure: Teach me how to do this.
Katrina:  这就是汉堡包
Katrina: This is a burger.
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
俢硕；夹花
Shure: Sandwich.
Katrina:  做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who can't make a puppy?
Shure:  他说他习惯了做狗
Shure: He said he's used to making puppies.
Katrina:  做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who can't make a puppy?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 做狗谁不会哈哈哈
Lucia: Who can't make a puppy? Hahaha.
Katrina:  今天要有太阳就好
Katrina: It'd be nice if it was sunny today.
Tasha: 真的3星了
Tasha: Really, it's three stars.
Nicous: 而你是我真正的
Nicous: And you are truly mine.
Tasha: 哎呀刚刚把装备人全卖了
Tasha: Oh no, I just sold all the gear and people.
Tasha: 现在搞一搞
Tasha: Now I gotta fix it.
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh.
Lucia: 太鼓了
Lucia: So stubborn.
Tasha: 他怎么上不上去装备了
Tasha: Why isn't he equipping the gear?
Nicous:  靠你上你给的是那个哎
Nicous: You said it was that one, right?